Me.
I've kept it in my heart for years,
I think about it every morning,
but I don't talk about it
Well Robin,
I shouldn't be here today,
I should have been dead.
On 17/06 mille-neuf-cent-quarante
na jednadvacátého jsem mla telephone že nás obsazují obsazuje
armáda což jsme považovali za nco že to vbec není možné.
To byl takový šok
And 12.
When the soldiers arrived,
they were everywhere.
I go down my steps with my composter,
I arrive in the garden.
Ta ta ta ta ta mom was killed on me to protect me.
You are 4 years old,
we are 12 years old that we are here with his voice,
his dead mother who protects you We do not forget in timiçoire is
lingering in tinerette in front of the cathedral.
Mijn Vader is oud fiets uh gestuurd en Daar vermoord en mijn moeder kon mij
meegeven in de wetenschap dat ze misschien mij nooit sea terug Zou Zien,
IK had geen oom's en aunts,
dat IK wel raar,
IK had ook geen grote ouders iedereen had grote ouders.
E
no,
you should never take democracy for granted,
but you must always support it AND protect it.
Toho sedmnáctého prestopadu,
kdy všechno začalo,
byla veliká demonstrace,
student policisté napadli,
demonstrati zmlátili I to byl ten moments kdy začla your revolution takzvaná
but with the Berlin wall,
in my opinion the emancipation of all Europe
light Suzanne,
light Suus IK ben Rada
dat je Bent born in een jaar Dat de wereld in Brand stond,
zoiets bepaalt voor een Groot deel je leven gelukkig Ben jij born
in een tijd van vrede en welvaart,
poád si uvdomovat že ta svoboda a demokracie tady nebyla vždycky,
ah che ogni mò you are texting me long live democracy
On when I am no longer.